tonight we honor those women and men
whose careers have transformed our
industry we honor those who set new
standards of excellence we honor those
who have touched us with their talents
which is why we honor my friends Kathy
Kennedy and Frank Marshall
individually and together
there's ranks on a very short list of
the greatest careers in Hollywood
history and you can tell that by the
fact that we know who they are just like
all of the legends simply by their first
names the Stevens the Clint's Cicely
Cathy and Frank no last name required in
this town it's just an incredible body
of work that they both have so just to
put it in personal perspective I did the
Jason Bourne movies with Frank and
that's probably like the pinnacle of my
career I don't think they make Frank's
top 10 and as for Cathy at this point
probably not even her top 20 so but I
think the most remarkable thing about
them and admirable is the way they treat
everyone who works with them and it
comes from the fact that they love what
they do so much and because of that they
love and respect all who were involved
with them on every project they're
always so supportive of all their people
and I am proud to be one of their people
not just because they've created these
incredible careers but because they are
two of the best human beings I've ever
met so tonight it is a privilege to be
here with them as they receive yet one
more well-deserved accolade